anything I can answer for you how much
Boehner Boehner like just you know my
day just filled with headaches and I'm
just trying to like like I really meant
what I just said to you like I work for
you like I don't know what else to tell
you so like when you take on the
responsibility to be the last line of
defense
it's all your fault like all of it
and so I feel a huge gratitude and
everybody's trust and a huge sense of
responsibility to deliver for everybody
like like I think we're really building
something for real like not just lip
service it's just very black and white
to me I know we are and I want to see it
through and I want to really deliver so
I feel like like great pressure you know
it's just five offices eight hundred
people almost now not to mention all you
know just like all the other stuff that
goes along with like my life like the
content and the books and the speaking
and being pulled in a million directions
it is a lot but like I made my bed I
can't complain about sleeping in it you
know yeah and like and then lets them
really get to the punch line in the
world of eight billion people it's good
I'm gonna be okay like do you know what
I mean
like I couldn't even begin to I think
coming from immigrant background and
things that nature like my perspective
is on [ __ ] point
like I very aware of how awesome it is
so yeah it's a lot of pressure great so
then don't do it sell the company
downsize it like I've made it so like
and I like want instill that on the rest
of the org like you're a big girl like
whatever problems like you like like my
biggest reason I'm giving you this
little rant is I want you to know that
if you ever have anything I'm here like
email me like you know like how do you
even met Claude yet you have to email
her right now like I'm I'm forcing you
like you have to go to your desk and
email her and be like I want her to know
who you are like like this horseshit
like like that like is this
like it's way more real than you think
take advantage of it like you stumbled
into it
[ __ ] take advantage of it do you
understand yeah you know like it's good
and you should like get the most benefit
from it cool you're welcome have a great
day